bonsoir Monsieur la casse
bonsoir alors en vous reçoit au
lendemain de l'annonce de la Banque du
Canada qu'elle était inchangé le taux
directeur à 4h30 pour cent on y voit une
bonne nouvelle pour le marché immobilier
est-ce que c'est votre impression aussi
c'est aussi notre impression
effectivement on a une lecture qui est
assez similaire au rapport dont on
faisait étant un petit peu plus tôt donc
la confiance finalement est revenue du
côté des acheteurs on les a senti un peu
plus frileux depuis septembre dernier
mais avec des taux d'intérêt qui se
stabilisent avec une économie qui est
forte des prix aussi qui sont assez
stables les acheteurs reviennent en plus
grand nombre oui
est-ce que une certaine partie des
acheteurs oui alors l'augmentation du
prix des propriétés puis l'augmentation
des taux d'intérêts ont fait en sorte
que certains acheteurs ne pouvaient plus
se qualifier pour la propriété qu'il
convoitait maintenant ils ont dû faire
des compromis il y a des propriétés
maintenant qui sont accessibles pour eux
ils vont se tourner parfois plus vers la
cour propriété que qu'une maison
unifamiliale par exemple mais il y a de
l'espoir alors ils sont effectivement de
retour est-ce que vous sentez justement
qu'en général le déjà été revu à la
baisse avec les taux d'intérêt qui sont
plus élevés le coût de la vie aussi qui
a augmenté ce que les gens cherchent
justement plus un condo ou une maison de
plus petite taille pour que ça coûte
moins cher au final
justement si on se parle de leur budget
je vous dirai qui sont beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus près de leur budget que
durant la pandémie la pandémie faisant
en sorte que on ne pouvait pas contrôler
le prix qu'on paierait une propriété
alors maintenant il contrôle leur budget
on a vu décroître la surenchère et on a
vu augmenter le nombre d'offres qui sont
féconditionnelles à la vente de la
propriété de l'acheteur ce qui avait
pratiquement disparu du radar des
dernières années alors donc le marché
est en changement puis en ce moment on
transige beaucoup plus près du prix
demandé alors c'est important que les
vendeurs aussi réalise que leur prix
doit être réaliste donc vous disiez
diminution des surenchères est-ce qu'il
y en a encore des offres multiples des
surenchères dans le marché
il y en a encore effectivement parce que
comme les taux notre niveau d'inventaire
est bas bien il reste que il y a
certaines propriétés qu'ils arrivent sur
le marché qui sont encore uniques alors
si on a un grand bassin d'acheteurs qui
vont la convoiter bien on risque d'avoir
de l'assurance cher mais ce qu'on a vu
apparaître aussi c'est des bases de prix
donc un vendeur qui va
mettre sa propriété sur le marché à un
prix un peu trop optimiste son prix
était un peu trop optimiste de
l'importance de travailler puis
d'écouter son courtier si on se
positionne à un prix réaliste à ce
moment-là non seulement on augmente nos
chances de vendre mais on augmente aussi
nos chances d'attirer plus d'un acheteur
est-ce que c'est un bon moment justement
pour les vendeurs ou est-ce qu'il
devrait attendre parce que les prix vont
augmenter
écoutez la synchronicité pourrait pas
être meilleur en ce moment autant pour
les acheteurs que les vendeurs donc les
tours d'intérêt sont stabilisés les prix
sont stabilisés l'économie tourne très
bien en ce moment là le niveau d'emploi
est très bon et c'est le temps au
printemps souvent de reconsidérer son
projet d'habitation en vue des prochains
mois de la saison estivale donc les
conditions sont gagnantes mais on dit
souvent que marcher est vendeur ou
acheteur qu'est-ce qu'il en est en ce
moment
il est toujours à la faveur des vendeurs
parce que les niveaux davantage sont bas
mais en ce moment on voit que il s'en va
vers une certaine un certain équilibre
qu'on pense atteindre possiblement en
2024 mais pour le reste de l'année c'est
encore avantage vendeur est-ce que des
marchés qui sont plus actifs que
d'autres en ce moment vous parliez de
copropriété tout à l'heure mais est-ce
que c'est plus fort que les maisons
est-ce que les nouvelles constructions
sont plus populaires que les anciennes
est-ce que vous voyez des tendances dans
ce sens là
oui la copropriété est à la hausse étant
donné son prix d'achat qui est souvent
moindre et comme l'acheteur a perdu un
petit peu de son pouvoir d'achat au
cours des dernières années il va se
tourner vers une copropriété plutôt que
une maison ni familiale malgré que
l'unifamial se porte très bien le plex
donc les propriétés à revenu
faire un petit peu de la pâte parce que
là on oui ça intéresse plutôt des
investissements avec les taux d'intérêt
c'est ça c'est moins rentable donc les
plex souffrent un petit peu plus et il y
avait beaucoup d'intérêt pour les
régions avec la pandémie est-ce que ça
c'est du passé est-ce que il y a encore
ce désir de d'aller un peu à l'extérieur
des grands centres
c'est toujours présent les marchés à
l'extérieur de la région de Montréal
sont toujours actifs je pense que le
télétravail est là pour rester donc il y
a des gens qui n'ont pas eu l'occasion
d'acheter qui tentait de passer au
travers de la pandémie mais qui peuvent
se permettre aujourd'hui de s'éloigner
des grands centres urbains alors on voit
encore beaucoup d'activités dans les
banlieues et aussi dans les centres de
vilégiature merci beaucoup d'avoir été
avec nous vous souhaite une bonne saison
il y a beaucoup beaucoup de vendeurs qui
seront très actifs j'imagine au cours
des prochaines semaines merci beaucoup
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]